morning guys
all right so we're back to our workout
with sensei today we're gonna do the
same kind of workout so same intensity
levels we did last week
the only difference we're gonna add two
minutes to the warm-up in two minutes to
the calisthenics part we're still going
to about a five minute six minute
meditation somewhere in there so still
easy right we're still working on this
if you feel like these are too easy do
them a couple times more a week right so
if you're still in pretty good shape and
you should be able do them easily
otherwise this is getting you moving
again depending on your amount of
soreness is how much you should decide
that you're doing them all right let's
get started
keep going see that you can't see the
ground here's gonna be trouble in a
second
yeah I think right in reaching up
forward and down hang let the let the
lower spine decompress a little bit get
me back up arms out
don't behind the back you know lock
fingers big breath in the chest forward
down
Circle the everybody
well the direction
and back up release the hands to one
side
back over to LA
Oh
company sitter rocking back and forth
pillows on the knees try and get a nice
low position and into the middle spread
feet yeah and sitting back nice straight
spine big breath in turn it down
back to center breath in turn it down
that consider heat together a nice
straight spine to keep your spine up as
much as you can turn out to really round
it bringing the feet in use the elbows
push the knees down drop the chest in
order to keep the back straight
crossing the ankles from on the stomach
can't write anything shoulders parking
up push to the head make sure the head
is reaching back
you shouldn't be full with your spine
the stretchy feel on your stomach so you
need your back
and back down keep the ground push the
hips back we're trying to push the heels
towards the mat here sitting here taking
the back of my legs drop your knees
sitting straight back
good okay so where you go through the
the wrist stretches here so first one
we're gonna do is cut a guy so I'm gonna
take my hand and put it right in front
of my face like this take by the hand
return grab the base of my thumb then
I'm going to turn that thumb towards you
guys you'll turn your thumb towards me
then I'm going to sink my hand down in
front so you can see how I have my hand
here got sideways I'm twisting my wrist
over to the side this is called caught
the guy all right other side palm
towards my face we try and grab the base
of my thumb twist the thumb towards you
guys you'll turn your thumb towards me
then when I sink my hand down this is
cooked the guy I have my hand using one
hand to push it over and twisting my
wrist now song Keo so I'm gonna put my
elbow up in the air palm towards you
guys reach around grab the base in my
index finger so I'm grab my index finger
and turn the thumb towards you you'll
turn your thumb towards me then I'm
gonna push my hand to the side this is
some kill some kill is third principle
good and other side elbow low palm
facing you guys return you have to base
my index finger thumb towards you you'll
turn your thumb towards me push the hand
to the side son kill should beginning a
stretch all through your forearm up into
your elbow then you should be able to
feel it from your elbow and into your
shoulders right now I can heal my
shoulder here so I'm kind of stretching
all through that whole area good next
we're gonna do unique yoni gives a
little tricky I'm gonna make a ring with
my index finger my thumb or a pumped-up
that ring flat on the palm of my hand
then I'm gonna pull my hands back so my
fingers are all pointing at you guys and
I'm gonna push my elbow for trying to
put point my elbow u2's notice how my
fingers and my elbows are both pointing
at you I'm pushing here on the side of
my hand like this
this is knee kill knee is - in Japanese
fuel is principal lesson so this is the
second principle of idea
[Music]
and the other side and make that ring
there's our time but it flat them pull
my hand push it back and we have me yo
so I'm pushing the side of my hand both
my elbow pointing you and my fingers are
pointing you which means your fingers
and elbow should be pointing it means is
you're trying to point me with both of
them kind of goofy and you push your
hand sideways while you're doing that
neat kill all right go ahead and shake
the hands out we're gonna work some legs
and some shoulders today okay so we're
gonna start with our arms straight out
like this pike circles in other
direction so it's going forward at first
I'm going back doesn't matter which
order you go in but circling your arms
tight circles other direction and other
direction good we're gonna bring our
hands in front of our chest like this
when elbows are pushing together my
hands are flat like this I'm gonna reach
out with my hands like I'm rest stroking
through the water so I'm flushing
through water or something I come back
here behind my back and keep my hands
palm up but I go underneath my armpits
I'm coming under my armpits crossing my
hands and going back out here then I'm
gonna lean back good come back up hands
come in under my armpits opposite way
bring them in and back in front of my
chest
so hands out going through the water
palms up going under my armpits keep the
palms up leaning back back up palms up
we'll try and keep your palms up my
humps are still up still up still up
still axilla let me get here bring mover
and back in out through the water they
breath in
Oh cross the hands plums up thumbs up
thumbs up and in get out through the
water under the armpit back and in under
the armpits
palms up thumbs up thumbs up in and
close out do the water
big breath breathing out cross the hand
palms up and the end Wow
through the water thumbs up out put your
hands in front I'll just hang up staying
up staying up sitting up staying up and
the end good all right but hold both my
arms out to my side like this hey I'm
gonna bring one hand in forward to my
stomach if they do that I'm gonna get my
stomach out of the way somebody come in
like stomach out of the way
palm up like I had a cup of water in my
hand I'm gonna come towards my face when
I get my face out of the way and over
here I'm coming towards my stomach
stomach out of the way I'm up look at a
cup of water one hands and back till
like a half cup of water on each hand I
don't want to turn that cup of water
over right so I'm here belly out of the
way head away Baddeley out of the way
yeah so like I want to move my arm in
one place and my body's got to move so
my arm can move in that one spot so you
can like you're a waiter in a restaurant
you got a tray full of glasses and you
don't want to spill that tray I'm doing
this really don't spill the tray
good okay now I'm out arms out both
pumps up okay I might have one shoulder
all the way over and my palms up on this
side palms up on both sides this
shoulders down now that I replaced that
so one shoulder goes up the other show
that goes down back and forth shoulder
to shoulder you want to work dynamic
tension when you're doing this I mean
you're working your muscles gets
themself so it's never easy I'm not just
just going like this right I'm actually
stretching using the muscles against
each other as I go should start doing
this right away the shoulders you don't
feel like the shoulders not trying hard
enough so you got it close your
shoulders against each other so it's
difficult every action open I'm rolling
shoulder one way and shoulder the other
way back and forth say look like
someone's twisting me pulling my arms on
both sides one shoulder down one
shoulder up you feel any of your
shoulders right now good all right
arms out thumbs up and we're doing it
we're just standing here
arms out shoulder should feel tired like
they eat you a little bit that's good
all right we're going to slowly squat
down so feet together slows down arms
are still out nothing's changed keep
your balance and squat down good knees
down flat and nice as a position palms
still up aren't you still straight to
keep your arm straight level don't let
them drop a little don't let them raise
me right now nice and straight palms
down
I made that little switch there felt in
your shoulders so probably I'm happy
about that
all right now saving this position when
you go back to the balls of our feet so
behind holding my feet I'm gonna bring
my knees up your balance then when you
come up nice and slow
not super fast coming up coming up
coming up here we go good
and holds up
if you gather good and flat comes down
tight circles tight circles other way
your shoulders should be doing it tight
circles the other way and the other way
good ones up slightly again slightly
again slightly again slightly again
slightly again straight overhead
straight up overhead I'm slowly down in
front of you so this good will come out
here like a zombie or something arms out
to the side good use the folder times
the two my legs sorry about that
and slowly down your size so inside your
legs introduced in shoulders today
alright okay guys get your meditation
I'm gonna stick with observational
meditation
mostly because I think it's one of the
most useful kinds of education is the
most practical and utilitarian because
teaching your mind to just be okay
whatever is going on and the level of
difficulty will get ramped up naturally
inside of yourself the longer you sit
because you know you'll get the desire
to itch or desire to move around or your
managers start saying I'm hungry or
whatever tired or whatever stay awake
don't fall asleep stay with a nice
posture so your spine should stay
straight the whole time you really
shouldn't be moving right so look if a
wasp lands on your head you knock the
wasp off but like
you know you're you don't want to move
around a lot so you're gonna stay as
calm as you possibly can
we'll do three knocks of the bell in
we'll sit for about five six minutes
someone there and then three three not
to the bail out if you hear the timer go
off ignore it
[Music]
okay guys so that's our meditation
thanks for tuning in if you have any
questions anything you can ask in the
comments below so I was planning to hit
shoulders and like today but I didn't
think about that I have to explain all
the material looking brand new to you
guys so it took me a little longer so
next class we'll work a little more on
legs although I'm going for a kind of
intense hike Wednesday so it'll be hard
for all of us so yeah but same this week
will be the same intensity level pretty
pretty easy and then we're just going to
ramp up the time and then next week
we'll ramp it up one more time so our
total time on these workouts eventually
will be 10-minute our warm-up stretch 10
minute for our calisthenic period and
then I don't know maybe maybe 10-minute
eventually meditation but we'll go kind
of 5 6 7 8 like that so we'll take a
little longer to ramp up on the
meditation mostly you don't need to sit
with me meditation for that you can sit
on your own but it's nice sometimes to
have someone guiding you through the
meditation so that's the basic course
then once we get up to that hopefully
the Doge is gonna be your opening next
month I hope still don't have any real
clarity on that but hopefully that will
be happening but once we get up to the
full time limit then I'll go to medium
workouts and then hard workouts as we go
all right thanks for watching and we'll
see you guys later